my name is Jennifer Lawrence and I'm
going undercover on the Internet this is
actually me let's start with Cora calm
why are there so many pictures of
Jennifer Lawrence showing the middle
finger cuz I'm an [ __ ] how can I get
a date with Jennifer Lawrence
honestly just ask me I have not been
touched by a man in a very long time is
Jennifer Lawrence becoming a chameleon
like Meryl Streep no absolutely not I
don't have the talent threshold what are
a few of the best Jennifer Lawrence
memes I have no way of knowing I would I
would rather die and watch a meme with
myself how would you describe Jennifer
Lawrence in one word nice nice which
Jennifer Lawrence items should I get a
hardcore fan for Christmas Katniss
Barbie right reddit our Brad Pitt and
Jennifer Lawrence dating no but I'm not
super excited to shut that rumor down
Wikipedia yes it's me you know
Lauren says that she finds acting quote
stupid and does not believe in being
quote cocky about her success as a role
model to young people she tries to be
careful with her words well I think that
we all know that that's not true so we
can just delete that never really made
it there Lauren said that she knew from
an early age is who be famous just
delete that I'm never drinking in an
interview ever again I don't know why I
said that and that quote has been
haunting me for my whole life so just
delete
Betty at mail.ru does Jennifer Lawrence
who started in hungry games speak in
Russian no I don't do that YouTube do
you think it's a coincidence that Reggie
Bush's wife looks just like you I go can
Jennifer Lawrence have her own talk show
already I'm honestly not good enough it
was only because it was Kim I wouldn't
be good at that
I like Jennifer Lawrence but she always
seems drunk well I'm not ever drunk when
I'm working on the weekends maybe I
think that's probably just be reacting
to nervousness I feel like Jennifer
Lawrence is that one best friend who
just walks into your house eat your food
right out of your fridge tries on your
clothes and drinks all your wine
yeah that's pretty right yep
Instagram Jennifer's first pet was a
schnauzer named Ozzie he hated Jennifer
and her family so much that he never
wanted to be in the same room as them as
irrelevant as that may be it's
absolutely true Ozzie hated us you know
how dogs normally like to stay in the
room where people circulate and most he
always stayed in the opposite room
Twitter how does Jennifer Lawrence even
exist are we sure she's a real human I
don't know how to respond to that I can
assure you I'm all too real
unfortunately
why doesn't Jennifer Lawrence have
Twitter does she not realize how amazing
her tweets would be if I knew how to
hook my phone up to Wi-Fi then that
would be a different conversation is it
me or does she look like a Hungarian
Jennifer Lawrence
I guess she kind of looks like me yeah
was Jennifer Lawrence naked with body
makeup in the x-men movies or was it a
skintight suit it was both for the first
movie I was naked with body paint and
for the last three
I've had a suit how does Jennifer
Lawrence not know what a 3d printer is I
have no idea what a 3d printer is the
idea of that and what somebody tried to
explain to me like blows my mind that
that could exist they finish no sense I
am do be calm
trademark slightly husky voice mm-hmm
witty sense of humor that's nice often
works with David O'Russell and Bradley
Cooper um not careful with what she says
kind of a mess but overall pretty nice
lady that was me the entire time the
accounts for me I drank for eight hours
well doesn't look good thanks